she's brave and she said Danica your
fanbase is uniquely different being the
only female driver in the top national
series is that a role you really embrace
yeah but I had to come into it I would
say it's a role that I took on because I
wanted to have something to say I wanted
to be impactful in some way and a
positive role model that doesn't just do
something but says something to don't
really made me think it was a
thought-provoking thing
when you hear girls say I feel like I
can be a racecar driver
because Danica did it what impact does
that have on you that's big because it's
really hard and just because I did it
doesn't mean you can do it but it means
that it's impacted them in such a way
that they have instilled a level of
confidence in themselves based on what
they see where do you get the idea for
something unless you have seen it
my sister wanted to race and then I just
didn't want to get left out so I owe her
Wow yeah big time I was ten which is so
cool that I'm number 10 now because I
was 10 when I started
oh yeah that's your number good perfect
there are so many young girls that
follow you from racetrack to racetrack
and we thought it'd be pretty cool to
surprise a young group of them they
don't know you're here but they're
actually next door and we've been
rolling on them with our cameras as they
could have talked about you so really
yeah they said nice thing I think I
think they're lovely but let's take a
listen that's okay because she's the
only girl in the league
she says that girls can do anything yeah
cuz she shows that it's not just a man's
sport
she was the first girl to stand up in
the sport and she shows that you can be
whatever you want to be even if your
girl or a boy or a girl or boy didn't
catch it because she can still do it
even though she's short and I think
that's important because I'm short too
you want to go surprise them I do okay
let's go say hi
Danica Patrick is brave and I can be
blamed
Danica Patrick is fast and I can be
faceted so you can do it I Danica's
courageous and I can be courageous to if
Danica can be tough I can be tough too